踏まれた　花のなまえも
知らない
地に落ちた鳥は
風を待ちわびる
祈った所で
何も変わらない
今を替えるのわ
戦う覚悟だ❗️
屍踏み越えて
進む意志を
笑う豚よ
家畜の安寧
虚偽の繁栄
死せる餓狼の自由を❗️
囚われた屈辱は
反撃の嚆矢
迸る殺意に
その身を
やきながら
黄昏に緋を穿つ
紅蓮の弓矢
wwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwwww
あ、今回は先に言っておくんですけど、
今回は間違いなくおこられます。(母親＝プンプン)
怒られる事を覚悟でやりますよ(キリッ)
お母さんごめんなさい。(かーらーのー机💥)
というわけでお前達、
ピーナッツって知ってるか？ピーナッツ(なぜ2回言った？)
こういうｘ３ピーナッツっていうな、
別にバタピーじゃなくていいんだ。(「周りにバタピーしか無い！」っていう人は別。)
これは俺が小学校の時だった。
ちょっと魔が差してな。
鼻の穴にな、ピーナッツを入れたらな、(ピーナッツを入れたら？！)
取れなくなっちゃたんだよ(なんだそれだけか．．．)
まじで取れなくなってェェェ
鼻にピーナッツを入れると、まじでとれなくなるんすよ。(あぁ、そう。)
「この動画を真似しろ」って言ってるんじゃないよ。(いや、真似する奴．．．crazy guy!)
俺がね、このおお大人になった今ね、
実際にその、鼻にピーナツを入れてさ、、、、
それ、取れなくなった、この、哀れな大人を見て、
お前たちに学んでほしいんだよ。(予知園児でもあるまいし、する訳ねえだろ？)
あ、鼻にピーナッツ入れちゃだめだなって、
これを見てピーナッツの危険性を知ってほしい
マジで取れなかっただもん。
多分めっちゃ泣いた覚えがあります
ピーナッツ、、、じゃあイきます
やべまじで救急車とか呼んだらどうしよう。
あの、マジで真似すんな！
さきに言っておこうこの動画は、
ピーナッツが危ないってことを、
皆さんに教える動画なんで。
まじでまねすんなよ！！！
じゃあイきますｘ2
頼むぞｘ2　あーやべえほんっとうにやばい
マジで取れなくなるんだよな。(ふーん　そうなんだ。)
あ、だめだ！やばっ！！！
良い匂い♡
あ、やばい！
あ、やばい！！もう取れない！
ちょっと待って、(ぶふっ←鼻の音)
あ、え、やばい！ええ！あ、やばい！あ、え、あ、(からの、鼻の音そしてぴーなっつが出た)
もうちょいイけるな♡
もう目で確認でえきないとこまでいったら、やヴぁいんだよ。
もうないでしょ。
もう、手でとれないんだよ。
これがねェ、
僕今普通の顔してますけどおお、
大分緊急じたいです。。。。。。。。
もう手で取れないんで、
ちょっとやばいんすよお。(小声で)
ふゅっふゅっ(鼻の音)からのピーナッツが飛んでいく
まだ大丈夫、まだイける。
手で取れなくても
このォ鼻でね、ふっふっ←(鼻の音)ってやれば、まあ、なんとか、なるんで
覚えといてください。
や、ヤ、殺れとは言ってないよ。
もうちょいイケるな
あ、もう、あ、完全に見えねえだろ。
これがね緊急事態なんだよ。
ま、う、な、あ、やべっ！！！これやべえ、こらやべえわ(慌ててる感じ)
ふｎ、ふｎ、あ！、ふｎｎっ！
やばい、あ、やべえ、やべえ完全に入った(ピーナッツが)
もう、見えないでしょう？！ふｎ！あ、(完全に気ずいた)やばい！！！！やばい！！
ふｎ！ふｎ！ふｎ、ふｎ、ごはっ！え？えっ？嘘っ？ふｎ！ｘ3あ、あ、あ、やばい！んーヤバい！
とれない！取れない！！(何度も言うがピーナッツが)ふｎｎっ！(からの)おは！おはっ！
アアあああ(ヤバいｘ多分6回)
完全にヤヴァイ！完全にイった♡
ヤバい！！ふｎｎｎｎｎふｎｎｎおほっ！おほっ！(ふｎｘ34567回)
はあ、はあ、はあ、ヤバい！エエ、嘘？！ハクションっっっ(そしてピーナッツが出た！)
ボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボチボンボン
wwwwwwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwwwwwwww
wwwwwwwww
和――――――――――キャーーーーーーー